tent vehicles are going next online at
cspan.org
local content
you're watching american history tv also
examines the social changes of the 1970s
and the effects of watergate and the
vietnam war the rise in divorce rates
and drug incarceration panel also delves
into why we associate the 1970s with
crises and disintegration of american
life
we recorded this discussion at the
american historical
all right well welcome everybody to the
uh to today's panel on cr the crises of
the 1970 panel today and um
i
i'm going to just start out by talking
about what we thought we were going to
what how we kind of finally all of us
were going to speak for maybe about 10
minutes so kind of brief just making a
few brief remarks about
the literature on the 1970s what this
unique time means to us today
and then we'd like to open it up and
have a lot of time for conversation both
among both with each other and all and
um
and hopefully having a lot of time for
conversation
so one of the things that we were
thinking about in setting up this panel
is the central in thinking about the
1970s both in the contemporary political
imagination of the time and also in
historical scholarship from one sense of
danger and awareness of historical
change
and histories of the decade too often
treated in these kinds of heightened
terms observed the the period of 1970s
has gone from being a kind of easily
dismissed historical footnote or a kind
of you know a punchline of some scene is
in some ways as a moment when many of
the
things that we're most aware of in our
own present world really came into
existence history sent in the invisible
bridge
laura calman's right star rising
nostalgia
no direction home jeff cowie staying
alive annalise orlak and maurice
chappelle
nancy mclean's work on affirmative
action
stephanie gilmore and valk and alice
eckles on feminism and many other books
um have really gone back to the 1970s in
recent years as we've seen this real
revival
and expansion of scholarly various
different areas of american life to be
experienced as fraught with crisis at
this moment in history and what is at
stake in defining this one of crisis
um
don't do we how does the whole idea of
crisis
complicate things for us as historians
if that's how we want to set things up
are there important areas about the
important connections between the
different areas that we're thinking
about on this panel the national
politics and state structure family and
sexual relationships race the prison
system
cities international politics or do we
see the aiming our first panelist is
beverly gage um beverly is a professor
of history 20th century american history
at yale university her the day wall
street exploded a story of america in
its first age of terror looked at the
history of terrorism in the late 19th
and early 20th centuries focusing on the
1920 of the former fbi director j edgar
hoover
who died in the 1970s
um beverly
i think
the protocol was that we would stand up
here for comments and then sit back down
when we get to the uh
um
so when i agreed to be on this panel at
kim's initiation i said that i would
talk a little bit about the intelligence
crisis of during the 1970s there was a
both
learning period in which americans
discovered a lot of things that they did
the fbi and the cia
and really the most notable feature of
that intelligence crisis was in fact
maybe not the death of j edgar hoover
those things so hoover died in may of
1972 so i think that's the most
important event of the 1970s but
uh the church committee rejected really
wide-ranging investigation into what the
intelligence agencies in the united
states have been up to
certainly since the 1940s and
but as i got into thinking about the
intelligence crisis i began to see all
sorts of connections to other crises
offer a little bit of a sense of what i
see going on
in national politics overall but
particularly in the mechanisms of
government in particularly the early
period of the 1970s roughly 1971 to
1976.
before i get into talking about that i'm
going to take the intelligence crises of
the 1970s for two other panels um one is
that if you're coming to the oah in
saint louis in april um we're going to
be the church committee which is going
to be this year 2015. we're going to be
joined by um fbi historians uh people
who have been staffers on the church
committee second panel that i just want
to mention briefly is actually going to
be at the aha
is uh very much in keeping with the
themes that we're going to be talking
about here on sunday night there's going
to be a screening of a terrific
documentary film called 1971.
see there relevance but 1971 is actually
about uh a break-in at the media
pennsylvania fbi office in 1971 uh by
anti-war active moments that set off the
intelligence crisis of the 1970s and the
files that were captured in that moment
um were one of the first ways that we
began to finding in the 60s and the
1970s so that is sunday evening there's
going to be a panel with the filmmaker
um and a journalist named betty medsker
who wrote a terrific book a break-in in
1971 i'll be there as well but that is
sunday night okay so uh the intelligence
crisis of the 1970s as i said
transformation of the institutions of
governance in washington in particular
during the 1970s i think we tend to
think about 70s as a period of
disillusionment with government as a
period when americans for the most part
retreated from politics the standard
view has 1870s become a period in which
americans retreat from politics in which
they become disillusioned about the
presidency about the intelligence
establishment about some degree about
the electoral process about political
parties and really step back from all of
this and i think that that narrative is
big disinclusion to that crisis of
legitimacy uh that is sort of the
broader crisis of governance in the
1970s um what some of the response were
and i want to throw out the idea that
actually far from being a moment of
retreat from politics the 1970s
particularly when you institutions of
governance really looked very different
by the end of the 1970s than they did at
the beginning of the 1970s and i would
even suggest the 1970s was as profound a
period of institutional change in terms
of the institutions of governance in
this country action of senators
city council governments
to some degree the invention of the
primary election but there are a lot of
chat and we recognize the progressive
era as a period in which these
institutions of governance change in
significant ways and i would argue or at
least sticking to 10-minute time limits
here so rather than go into great depth
about that i want to briefly uh point to
a few
moments of crisis moments of crisis in
the early 1970s and then point to some
of these institutional responses that as
i said are quite sweeping responses
about the crisis of governance in the
1970s i think there are a few images
that often come to mind maybe we're
going to talk about a long 19 push it
back into the late 60s and maybe push it
forward into the early 80s but in my
mind in many ways we want to start with
the 19th that something has gone wrong
in a deep deep way with electoral
mechanisms with party politics and with
the relationships between citizens and
political obviously there are lots of
other causes of this civil rights
vietnam in these brief remarks i won't
get into all of those but if we start
with 1968 see but a crisis about the
relationship between the president and
congress the relationship between the
president and the citizenry
and crises of the mid 1970s as i said
with the church committee etc so we have
all of these things together and if you
begin to look at what aspects of
american political institutions and so
uh to close my remarks here i just want
to list off a few of the changes that
happen a time in the early 1970s and i
think one of our challenges to think
about what some of the consequences of
those are and as kim said whether or not
these are seven uh we first of all get
millions of new voters in this country
right so you get a constitutional
amendment that makes the voting age uh
that's early in the 1970s you also get a
transformation of the primary system in
this country right
prior to the 1970s you have five or ten
years crises of its own uh that is also
birthed in the early nineteen seventies
uh you begin to get a transformation
that it oxidized but comes to fruition
in the 1970s of the ways in which
congressional committees are structured
you get really the breakdown of the old
congressional committee through much
more transparent uh congressional
committee structure during that period
the freedom of information act for the
first time really gains weight
particularly uh because of reforms in
1974 the foia had been passed in 1966
it does not really get teeth and ship
between the president and the congress
um and you begin to get a whole series
of intelligence reforms as well that
begin to come out on the watergate era
reforms uh you begin to get
congressional oversight of the
intelligence committees you begin to get
the fisa courts coming into it right
again
uh reforms that come out of watergate
and campaign finance reform so
all of this again we can go into some
detail about what any of these laws are
coming from but i think in total
this is a pretty serious rethinking of
american governance during this period
about the 1970s many of these reforms
were of course partial reforms they
didn't solve the problems they were
meant to solve and i'm about to finish
and to think about ways to uh change the
government to that effect some of them
were the products of deep
disillusionment with government but
overall it energetic push toward a
certain kind of democratization a
certain kind of new openness in american
government a certain kind of new
transfer incomplete and also turn out to
be flawed and to have unintended
consequences and in many ways we're
dealing with some of those unintended
consequences as well as maybe some
our next speaker is university she is
currently a fellow at the ralph bunch
center at ucla
this year and she is the author of
living for the city 2011.
she is currently at work on a book
called crack in l.a policing the crisis
and the war on drugs i'm going to
provide an overview of thinking about
some of the issues about the drug crisis
of the 1970s then talk about some of the
new historiographical literature and
then finally to be looked at
in a decade of perceived in multiple
overlapping crises nothing so much
embodied the sense of drift displacement
and uncertainty
president richard nixon warned the
public that illicit drugs represented
quote a growing menace to the general
welfare two years later nixon declared
and committed himself to waging an
all-out offensive against that deadly
enemy
on the streets and perhaps most
disturbingly for the mainstream public
illicit drug use by law popular
estimates ran as high as 20 percent of
returning u.s veterans self-identifying
as heroin users
contemporary scholarship has challenged
that figure but this is classic 1970s
our tour films like the deer hunter and
the french connection depicted a world
in which iconic masculinity and
legitimate authority found itself in
peril of the dominion and damage wrought
by vice drug consumption and
distribution so much so that radical
african-american activists of the era
denounce these productions
in which drug economies rather than
grassroots struggles for black power and
community control were rendered as the
central focus of black communities in
the 1970s continues to dominate popular
cultural representations of the 1970s
lesser understood is the role of the
state itself in generating this the
justified unprecedented punishment
campaigns that follow the passage of the
rockefeller drug laws in 1973
as state rhetoric and popular culture
crime
in this way one of society's most
vulnerable populations found themselves
directly in the crosshairs of
unprecedented repression policing the
crisis mugging the state and law and
order in conjunction with popular media
the state helped generate crisis to
justify the expansion of its power to
the to the english context provided a
rationale and justification for what he
calls an authoritarian consensus and the
adoption of newt knew an order
calling into question whether mugging
was even a real phenomena or a simple
construction hall highlighted the
interdependence of the state and popular
media every point is a simple one the
production of crisis itself served as a
means to expand state power
the same could be said of the us in the
1970s and is an important one for
historical studies of the decade the
successive federal and state wars on
drugs starting with nixon and the
rockefeller drug laws and beyond and the
modern crisis for the expansion of state
power and the need to consider it as
discursive practice as a his and the
need to consider its discursive practice
as a history this is certainly true for
the drug war and are arguably many other
realms of american policy making in the
1970s
so now i'd like to turn punitive
campaigns against drugs in the larger
literature of the 1970s one of the
challenges faced by scholars is how to
interpret this decade in the larger
school century history this is true for
two reasons one is empirical and the
other conceptual the first issue is that
like the broader literature on the
carceral state they're institutional
studies of specific campaigns and
agencies or social histories of
consumption and illicit distribution
very little has been written by
historians pioneer schneider jason glenn
and julie kohler houseman have addressed
substantial portions of this void but
much more remains to be written the
decade relationally
namely should the 1970s be understood as
an extension of the 1960s or as an
anticipation of the 19 yawned or should
we reject its status as bridge
altogether
and writing about the war on drugs as a
social movement historian
i find this particularly challenging of
non-stop movement for social change
domestically and internationally from
world war ii through the 1970s the
interrelated struggles for civil rights
black power and britain poor people's
movements trace an arc of inclusion in
which previously marginal groups were
able to gain greater access to the
liberal benefits of the state
on the electoral teas municipal regimes
and federally elected officials
milestones include the election of tom
bradley in la the creation of the
congressional black caucus the party's
impressive electoral showing in oakland
and gary indiana's hosting of the 1972
national black political convention when
looked at however right-wing ascendancy
of the 1980s touted by an earlier
generation of historians and journalists
who viewed the 1970s as a decade of
transition or in the words of tom as a
chain reaction culminating in the reign
of the reagan democrat
however an emergent literature has begun
to break down these polarized views of
the 1970s was not as definitive and new
as previously thought
as we know from the pioneering work of
elizabeth kai hinton the war on poverty
pre-stage time and even helped to create
the infrastructure for its mass
prosecution of youth of color
which received its fullest elaboration
in the youth services bureau and that
led to increased criminalization and
surveillance of black and brown youth in
an era of democratic liberalism
similarly work by kathleen freidel and
matthew last annuities with the post-war
era the bipartisan nature of mandatory
minimum sentencing and the central role
of liberals and crafting a punitive
anti-drug regime brenty heather thompson
naomi markawa vesla weaver and many
others kathleen freidel's exhausted work
the drug wars in america and drug war
and the larger post-war period as the
state responded to a crisis in
governance during a period of
intensification and expansion of
imperial state power we have america's
first drug war emphasizes the role of
dixiecrats in crafting punitive drug
policy as a means of fighting efforts at
police reform and reorganization
prohibition in cities rather than on
suburbs and rural areas and this is of
course taking place in the context of
the second great migration of cities
especially visible in the 70s and 80s
lasseter explores the roots of the
modern drug war and california's passage
of harsh mandatory minimums nearly two
two decades laws a perceived narcotics
crisis in la prompted a broad-based
mobilization against dope peddlers
racist anxieties focused on
mexican-american wolf and rat packs
implicit to this earlier discourse
of drugs and crime was a suburban crisis
narrative in which an epidural
threatened white middle-class
adolescents proximate to block black and
brown urban youth in response state
government criminalized non-white dope
peddler's goals to prevent the
prosecution of affluent white youth
in contrast to an older scholarly
literature that views the drug war as
reflecting the rise of their shows the
that southern california suburban drug
crisis was far from a republican
invention indeed established california
liberal democrats connect across
partisan lines
this collective work on america's first
drug war has helped to place the
perceived drug crisis of the 1970s in a
much broader temporal endeavor more work
needs to be done in the u.s itself to
heed stewart hall's framework to show
how the state engendered drug crises not
only through dis um on the subject comes
from the 1970s namely alfred mccoy's the
politics of heroin published in 1972.
it traces holistic drug crises at home
through exhaustive fieldwork in vietnam
in the late 1960s and early 1970s mccoy
demonstrated how the national security
mccoy's critical work on the link
between imperialism and drugs has
spawned several generations of critical
scholarship on the geopolitical
dimensions of the war on drugs including
clarence lusain's pipe dream blues the
writings of peter dale scott and
jonathan marshall and the more recent
contributions of kathleen freidel
susannah rice's the geopolitics of the
cold war and us militarism mccoy and the
scholarship in his wake has enlarged the
domain of analysis to explain the links
between illustration from the 1970s
forward
still there's remains much to be done
and what follows is a wish list of
things that that might further be
researched we have drug drug consumption
and distribution networks indeed gang
and organized crime historian will
cooley has called for labor histories of
drug dealing type of study presents
methodological problems with the
necessary reliance on state sources
historians can look to earlier eras of
historical writing most notably and
supplement them with oral history and
the rich body of drug ethnography and
economic anthropology
the concept of informal economy has
particular utility and how to think
about the interrelation between
marginalization in the formal economy
and participation in off-the-books
economic activity perhaps the prurient
fantasies that drive crisis narrative
and moral panics
a second empirical area that needs much
greater research is the war and gangs
initially eliminating in subsequent
years my current book crack in los
angeles placing the crisis in the war on
drugs attempts to approach this history
through a regional study of drug and
us's multiple wars on drugs is tracing
their symbiosis and prosecution through
related punitive campaigns against gangs
crime and in later years of this is
trash which was an elite gang unit that
later became crash
that's notorious uh because of the
ramparts scandal and it's mindy's
birthed the modern campaign against
gangs and laid the foundations for its
use in subsequent years in los angeles
for example much of the carceral
infrastructure for the city's war on
drugs relied on geographically targeted
gang sweeps together with anti-gang
legislation and prosecution tools
moreover the conflation of drug crimes
with street gang membership created a
comprehensive net for the
criminalization of non-white youth the
lapd's practice of excluding motorcycle
gangs in the post-war era and other
forms of white youth organization meant
that the category of gang itself became
inherently racialized by the early 1990s
nearly half of los angeles
black male population between the ages
of 18 and 30 appeared in the county's
gang database
so in conclusion historians of the 1970s
are in many respects placed in a
difficult position of denaturalizing the
perceived crisis of the era while at the
same time engaging in acts of historical
recovery to excavate the history that
underlay phantasms that naturalize the
state's unprecedented incarceration of
large segments of the american public
for non-violent offenses in the case of
the first drug war there is still so
much more to be known and the conceptual
question of whether its historical arc
is defined by its post-war past or dark
future remains to be cited remains to be
decided thank you
our third speaker is robert's day of all
in the family the realignment of
american democracy since the 1960s out
in 2012 from hill and wang and in 2003
of american babylon race and the
struggle for post-war oakland from
princeton university press
right
so i am also i also applaud beverly for
being able to do this off the cuff but
um i'm going to stick to script because
otherwise i'll be here all day and
and you won't be so happy about that
so i'm of the opinion
that if historians go looking for a
crisis they can likely find one
it's merely a matter of discursive
practice
as donna said
if by crisis we mean literally a crucial
turning point
conditioned by instability and perhaps
indeterminacy
sometimes crises are noisy and much
celebrated
as the energy crisis
the presidential or governing crisis
or the
my role this afternoon is to bring a
discussion of the family and the crisis
or perceived crisis in the family
instabilities
of the 1970s and i want to be clear
about for whom we might talk about a
crisis of the family in the 19th world
or discursive work
in donna's formulation and part of that
is because when we talk about
demographic changes and a much broader
view than just the decade of the 1970s
we really have to have a almost half dec
half century view from the 1960s into
the early 20s family in the 1970s in
three distinct ways very briefly
first
there was little doubt that the 1970s
saw the advent of american households
shifts that likely had multiple causes
and beg for greater historical inquiry
to this point they've largely been
demanding that conversation
some of these shifts will be
well known to even casual readers of the
new york times
there was a spike in divorce in the
overall divorce rate by the early 1980s
when the divorce rate leveled off for
the population as a whole
since then both marriage high high
income generally white collar americans
tend to marry later
divorce more rarely and have fewer
children than low income generally these
shifts and their differentiation by
class have yet to attract deep
historical study though they are clearly
related to an underlying course the
topic of the day in our own era
alongside and partly overlapping uh with
uh with these changing marriage and
divorce rates in female headed
households and households in which women
are the primary breadwinners at both the
bottom and the upper end of the income
scale the pew cent women were either the
sole or primary source of income
in 1960 the number had been 10 percent
it's not entirely clear however that the
19th century
that period was certainly important
another place where historians of the
decade or that era might weigh in
but what does seem clear extreme and the
growth in the female professor
professional class of the other
alongside these rather blunt measures of
household composition
the growth for instance in single-person
households single-person households with
children and single-person households
without children the growth in same-sex
cohabitation lesbian baby boom of the
1970s
by a variety of measures then the manner
in which americans constituted
households and made it understood
between the 1960s and the 1980s
whether any of this constituted a crisis
of the american family depends
subjectively on where one stood in the
larger discussion
in other words it's
it's a crisis depending upon where you
stand
but let me turn to the second framework
of family in the night called the
political or rhetorical or discursive
crisis of the family
largely separate from whatever the
statistics on household and family
composition deal of political work
it was not in this case a statistical or
demographic concept it was rather a
political one
the breakdown of protean foil for a
variety of political projects
on the campaign trail in 1976 candidate
jimmy carter mused along the following
lines lives
the root of the problem is the steady
erosion and weakening of our families
running against gerald ford for the
republican nomination that year family
17 times in a nationally televised
speech he had clearly come to do
important political work
most powerfully an evolution could be
constructed
within that generational coalition
family did a great deal of ideological
work and let me suggest briefly three
major
first family was an anti-feminist
rhetorical ballast set against the equal
rights amendment roe v wade government
subsidized child care activists
feminism
and lgbt rights were in this view not
the product of progressive shifts and
how civil and economic citizenship
believed but direct causes of family
breakdown
second
family alongside law and order
increasingly came to signify opposite
welfare campaigns that gathered strength
in the decades after the moynihan report
but it can be seen to in the christian
social movement of the christian school
movement that emerged as an end run
around school desegregation
uh in the south and in the family values
movement particularly though not
exclusively in the southern bible belt
came to signify came to represent a way
of talking about the appropriate
functions of government
as i've argued in all in the family
family in the 19th century rhetorical
vehicle for imagining a citizenry who
needed not economic security or equal
opportunity but moral protection
it emerged as a handmaiden to a vision
of government and objectives
in all of these ways families was far
less family was far less in crisis than
it was undergoing a profound political
re-articulate now this is not to suggest
that family was only a concept with
residents with resonance among political
conservatives or that its only role
wrestled with the ways family did or did
not could or could not constitute the
psychic moral and social world they wish
to inhabit important as they were and as
relevant as they are for historical
research among various subcultures and
american
groups
lack the cohesion
third and finally family was the site of
furious conflict and negotiation one
might even say crisis
feminists of various persuasions had
long argued that the male breadwinner
model of both economic life and welfare
state provisioning was outdated if not
oppressing a century
by the 1970s working-class feminisms and
liberal lean in style feminisms had
launched powerful challenges to this as
had third world and lesbian feminisms of
various kinds
this produced a legitimate crisis within
the frameworks of both welfare and
rights liberalism center left had
created in bursts in the 1930s and 1960s
if there was a crisis of the family in
the 1970s here arguably infestation a
deep difficult to resolve political
crisis in the center-left's
understanding of family in relation to
its vision of both state and society
we listen to the gay lib people we heard
from the abortionists but there were no
steel workers no pipefitters and worst
of all no plumbers
jeff used it in his book too
there are certainly other ways of
talking and thinking about family in the
1970s than those that i've all too
briefly outlined here but i want to i've
left out and i welcome the opportunity
to have my fellow panelists to hear my
fellow panelists on this score as well
thank you
our next week will be heather ann
thompson
um heather is currently professor of
history in the department of his uh
department of history new book coming
out next year from pantheon on attica
and the attica uprising
and
she has written widely not only for the
journal of american history and other
scholarly publications but also for the
atlantic
for the new york times and elsewhere
about mass and good afternoon
you hear me okay with this okay great so
like everyone else i kind of came to the
the topic today really about how do we
think about the 70s how do we write
about the 70s kind of taking a pause a
time out and what we think we do all the
time to really assess where do we play
everything that's already been said the
way that i
thought about this was that the 1970s to
me is really characterized or has been
characterized kind of central or primary
arguments and one of them we've heard
about which is that the 1970s is this
bridge decade um a turning point from a
period of radicalism to a period of
conservatism
and then the second is that the 1970s is
a decade of crisis
and i want to i will say about the
second which is that the 70s as a decade
of crisis it really is kind of
remarkable once i sat down to start
think about it how much in the middle
east southeast asia the energy crisis
which is of course related to the crisis
in the middle east but also uh really uh
it's about a driving middle class
the economic crisis uh recession after
decades of post-war prosperity the
welfare crisis
labor movement the crisis of the family
as robert mentioned the broader urban
crisis that um for for many years was a
paradigm many of them and of course in
my field the broader crime crisis of
this time period that will lead us to
mass incarceration of these crises
everyone that i mentioned
are deeply racialized
particularly who is allegedly causing
the problem what the christ's origin is
and again the kind of narrative is tied
to the first narrative about uh bridge
decade which was having to do with
things worth tiesing both of these major
characterizations the first that this is
a bridge decade the second that this is
in fact a decade of crisis regarding the
former i don't want to spend time on
that
but this idea that the 70s was a bridge
decade um
but particularly between radicalism and
conservatism i think the one wonderful
thing rob chase's work i hope my own
work on prisoner rights um you know it's
very clear that radicalism doesn't die
in the 1970s she ate the 1970s is a far
more contested decade much more
about a continuation of this content
contestation for power that that
activism really continues well past the
1970s and the other piece of that bridge
decade argument that i really take issue
with is that this is the decade that
kind of signals the death of liberalism
um my own work suggests that quite the
contrary this isn't the uh this isn't
the death of liberalism it's the racial
coming of age of liberalism
uh a moment when liberalism was really
put to task made to act to be clear
about what it really stood for
and what it really supported and so in
that configuration liberals don't so
much get killed off by the law and order
conservatives or even just parrot their
views to stay in power
but in fact they are faced with their
own challenges to their own authority
their own
challenges to their own uh
legitimacy in the body politic
that leads them in their own very
conservative directions and leads them
as as we've already heard to be
architects of many conservative programs
so it's not so much in my view that
liberalism dies in the 70s but actually
that civil rights activist again though
what i really want to talk about is this
idea actually instead about crisis
firstly it seems to me that we need to
be really clear uh what the implications
are because i think they're very serious
um we need to be clear about it because
then we can actually ask how much of a
crisis were we really in here's the
bottom in many different areas with the
economy with welfare with crime policy
et cetera and indeed if the policies
that led to so much crisis for example
were cain were bottom-up and
redistributive
then sadly the new policy direction the
nation would have to take and did was
more conservative fiscally and so they
know in fact it was a logical corrective
there was a crisis and of course these
policy correctives would have major
implications particularly on income
inequality gender inequality and i could
go on
here is the thing though as recent
histories of the 1970s have begun to
indicate this was perhaps not at all a
decade of crisis we're on the same path
here
um this is i will suggest a decade in
which crises are declared and asserted
to policy change
and that the stakes were very very high
and that the ways in which crisis and
again this is not just an
unimportant chicken and an egg i hope to
argue
um
so just take for example this isn't what
i want to focus on but just for a moment
you think about the welfare crisis this
idea that we have a welfare crisis in
the 1970s uh we have a new generation of
lazy people um that we see that this is
again a created crisis it's manufactured
it's exploited yes there were problems
with the welfare system mainly that it
was never funded well
and that there was never enough
political will to sustain it and i could
go on but the fact was that
to the extent that the welfare so it
gets declared as a crisis and indeed
when it gets declared as a crisis and
the best manifestation of this is we
need a logical policy corrective the
policy policy corrective in turn will
create crises it is going to create a
crisis of poverty it is going to create
a welfare crisis but not at all the
crisis that we could make similar
arguments about labor and and family and
everything else
in my own field i just want to quickly
end by talking about the crime crisis of
the 1970s because i have a lot of
attention lately
um and here's the way that we tend to
understand it i think we're getting away
from this historically but certainly in
the popular 1960s they begin to soar out
of control
and in response to that we get a policy
corrective the policy corrective is this
and unfortunately we're going to end up
with mass incarceration but make no
mistake about it we had to do this
because there was a crime crisis right
after it well my own work both as a
historian but also more recently on a
national academy's uh panel khalil uh
jabra muhammad and i were lucky hours
and days working with data and numbers
is this why we started the war on crime
was there in fact a crime crisis
and if no
this is again a created crisis
we begin a war on crime before we have a
crime crisis we chose this for very
complicated reasons that i don't have
time to go into that have everything to
do with pushing back at the system in
place at this path
and by choosing this path they in turn
generated a crisis
they in turn generated what will become
is it very differently i say it's a
crisis of violence
it's a crisis that is generated
when you have excessive homelessness
when you have is permanently
unemployable because they have a
criminal record
and again this gets us into a different
area but what it suggests is that crime
crisis is the changes of the 1970s not
generative of those policy changes and i
think that this is something we should
think about so we get crisis overhaul
the american economy social welfare
policies foreign policies criminal
justice system or whether they
preemptorially decide using the term to
do these things to prevent further
equality to prevent further income
redistribution to prevent greater labor
rights at large are vast
it could be that by getting the 1970s
wrong we might have totally
misunderstood the evolution of the
post-war period
the stakes were incredibly high in the
1970s that's why i think we need to
think about more less of a decade of
crisis and more of a decade of contest
states thank you
great and now i'm actually speak just
briefly myself so i'm going to introduce
myself and then i'll stand up so
um to have the two roles so i'm kim
phillips fine i'm a historian my first
book was called invisible hands the
businessmen's crusade against the new
deal and i'm working now on new york
city in the 1970s and the fiscal crisis
i'm in a book that will be published by
metropolitan books at some point in the
not very distant future
um
so
is the sense that 1970s new york has
been long a subject both of revulsion
but also of a certain kind of and i
think we've seen this even over the past
few weeks in the city's politics when
the decade has been invoked by the
police commissioner and many others
the two police officers in brooklyn to
the spate of violence against police
officers in the 1970s
the 1970s new york in one view was a
kind of spaciousness violence disorder
and chaos a city on the edge of
bankruptcy a city where thousands of
stores are destroyed the second the
lights go out in the black nobody wants
to go back to
an era of crime arson disinvestment and
abandonment and in some ways the entire
politics of new york has been defined
against this nightmare alternative
and yet at the same time coexisting with
this is i think a certain undeniable
real nostalgia i'm for the time when
there was an actual art scene in lower
manhattan even for the old smutty times
square for a kind of grittier lesson in
new york witness the success for example
of patty smith's loving memoir of the
period just kids
in a recent essay an excellent essay in
the magazine higher period of the 1970s
it's looking at a spate of recent novels
set during the decade and asking why so
many authors are drawn to view how sad
he asks does one have to be to want to
resuscitate the era of stagflation
so one might ask i think a similar kind
of question about the panel today i
think one of the reasons for the appeal
of the decade and part of the challenge
for historians but also why we're drawn
to it is this sense that eu historical
sensibility about what was happening the
sense of the period as one of
transformation and i think there's
something appealing about this feeling
of openness and urgency implicit in the
idea of crisis even if it's also fraught
with danger
so just to think about what this means
and what the challenges and
opportunities are that it offers just to
look back i think we we've talked about
some of the areas that were perceived as
being in crisis but one of the
interesting things about the time is
that many intellectuals also invoke this
idea that in his 1969 essay political
theory as a vocation for example the
political scientist sheldon wolin writes
about crisis as a kind of systematic
derangement so that social problems
appear not as random consequences of a
system which otherwise works tolerably
well but as the necessary result of a
more extensive set of evils which can
confidently be predicted to continue
producing similar results and i think as
as
as both heather and donna suggested the
sense of crisis the political function
of naming the naming of crisis means to
imply that things have reached an
intolerable point they cannot go on as
they have been some kind of change must
be forced into existence so naming a
crisis contains within itself the seeds
of action the sense a strong sense that
something must be done to alter the
situation if social order is to continue
at all it suggests a kind of compression
of historical time and i'm thinking
partly of some of janet reutemann's
writings on crisis where it's a kind of
definitive moment of transformation even
if it's anticipated by earlier events
the episode marks a dividing line
between the world as it was and the
world as it will be
and this is something roland wasn't the
only person to write a talk about this
um there was a sense in the 1970s of
course that the entire
world system of capitalism is entering
into a period of crisis an objective set
of difficulties that the old policy
tools cannot confront but will only
compound james o'connor for example
writes in 1973 about the fiscal crisis
of the state the idea that the slowdown
of the private and in the economic
slowdown and inability of the private
economy to keep generating ever higher
levels of profits will means that
there's a
intensifying competition for public
resources
and that this will lead the kind of
displaced social conflict into a fight
over the state these ideas are also
taken up by daniel bell and the cultural
contradictions of capitalism where he
writes both about the welfare state but
also about the deepening tensions
over the old social structures of
capitalism the bourgeois virtues of
discipline rationalism delayed
gratification and work and the new
cultural order emphasizing hedonism
consumer display and pleasure
and so i think in addition to wollon's
sense of crisis as a kind of subjective
experience um a kind of moment of naming
and a calling for a new direction
there's also a sense of crisis as this
kind of objective
uh moment when limits have been reached
and a social order cannot continue
forward as it has been
in new york and in my own work on new
york i've been very struck by the way
the rhetoric of crisis is invoked in
city politics really both by people on
the right and those on the left and for
conservatives of course the image of the
city as a ford apache um
is he became intimately a place of rise
in crime again very racialized language
very racialized sense of this rising
crime and sexual permissiveness this
sense becomes intimately linked to its
financial problems both are symbols of a
liberalism run amok the answer to both
is discipline through the police on one
side and through strict fiscal controls
on the other on the other side for the
left the problems of new york become
intimately connected to the unfolding
crisis of the post-war order and the end
of prosperity
so for both left and right the immediate
practical problem the city faced the gap
between its expenses and its revenues is
connected to a whole set of national
issues through the sensibility of crisis
so that the resolution of the problem is
no longer a simple question about
renegotiating debt but rather becomes a
chance to call for an entirely new
direction in city politics and for and
at times for a new direction for the the
nation as a whole
so i think
you know one of the
this is connected of course to the
larger shift from a sense of urban
crisis to the framework of fiscal crisis
and a a transformation in a sense that
the primary problem facing city
governments is
no longer how to address social problems
of poverty or racial injustice
but instead to find ways to safeguard
scarce resources in a time of decline
and in this sense fiscal crisis becomes
you know it's a moment
when the the city is near bankruptcy new
york's near bankruptcy and other cities
as well their fiscal problems are seen
as as due to a certain extravagance and
the problems and bankruptcy are kind of
just punishment
and in in this way it becomes a moment
of substituting a framework of treatment
or remedy for social problems with a
mode of discipline and retrenchment
and the frightening images of social
breakdown become part of a narrative
about the need to restructure fiscal
crisis then becomes a conservative
framework for thinking about the
problems of the city um and i think one
that as heather suggested is not it's
really not just it's not just one
adopted by the right but one that is
really used to reframe the commitments
of liberalism as well but here i think
we get to one of the problems of the
idea of crisis and i think i i
uh as a number of younger scholars have
suggested including some who are in this
very room um there are sharp problems
real problems with drawing this kind of
sharp line between the war on poverty
framework and what comes after um or
you know more broadly between post-war
liberalism and what comes after even
during the war on poverty many of the
ideas and practices that are sometimes
associated with neoliberalism or present
in nascent form
in new york in new york city the lindsay
years as actually one student that
robert and i share ben holtzman
is is working on the lindsay years of
the 1960s see seemed
the development of many of the
innovations associated with 1980s
such as
such as the use of real estate property
tax abatements
the aggressive efforts of city
government to stem the exodus of
industry even the proximate cause of the
fiscal crisis the use of the credit
markets to fund the local state rather
than taxation is a certain form of an
early kind of financialization
a way to try to use finance to evade
political conflicts so in some ways
framing the period as one of crisis or
accepting the period's framing of itself
in those terms can obfuscate or make it
harder to see these real areas of
continuity
and making it much more difficult to see
the ways that the assumptions and ideas
of the post-war years and of post-world
liberalism shape what comes afterwards
but finally to return to um nostalgia i
think that one of the i think that it's
not we shouldn't throw out the idea of
crisis altogether either that part of
what makes the idea the era such a
compelling one to study is this
awareness of collapse of an older social
order
and a sense that a divide was opening up
between the expectations generated by
the past and the new sense of the
realities of the present and future and
the fierce contest again as heather
suggested over
um over these possibilities and over
these conflicting expectations in the
specific case of new york they're both
the machine politicians of the city
including its mayor abraham beam for
some time as well as many different
activists and radicals continue to
articulate a variety of different
directions for the city's development
pressing both pressing for broader
national political changes that were
lessened the particular pressures the
city was facing um as as well as various
ideas about imposing limits on the
ability of banks to ought to sell off
the city's securities
so they attempted in a variety of ways
without much success but they still
attempted to to
to describe ways to solve the city's
problems while also laying claim to
part of the the
to avoiding the retrenchment that that
happened in the wake of the crisis
this is exactly the kind of idea that
within the city
a newly confident financial and business
community seeks to combat
joined by national politicians and by
city and state democrats insisting that
the old commitments of new york to free
tuition at the city university to a
certain model of public education to
cheap transit that's precisely these
commitments and expectations that make
recovery impossible
as felix or hawton the lazard ferris
banker who helped engineer the solution
to the crisis said in one meeting only a
kind of overkill in terms of budget cuts
would have necessary shock impact to
make it clear to investors across the
country that new york city was really
changing so in a way
at
what is at stake is the expectations
that people have within the city and the
expectations that people have of society
and government in general
and i think this sense of an error
about era being in flux of one set of
expectations giving way to another yet
still contested and not really accepted
at a deep level is part of what accounts
for this experience of crisis both in
new york and also more broadly and i
think it's also what accounts for our
attraction or at least for some part of
the attraction to the 70s today that we
see this as a kind of last moment of
life outside of
a certain kind of domination by the
market and the existence of a strong set
of alternative norms and expectations
before they're really discarded is
unrealistic and improbable and the
feeling of these slipping away and the
conflicting
and the conflicting expectations around
the era
market as one to those who live through
it as a time of crisis and is part of
what makes the period compelling the
scholars even now so
um i think i'll wrap up there and
i'll now shift back down here
and uh open it up for questions and
discussion
and i should say this panel is actually
being taped by c-span
so um you both might know that in making
any remarks and comments but also
also part of what that means is that
everybody should direct questions to the
microphone you have to actually get up
and go over to the microphone over there
so that they'll be able to capture the
questions
and and and people should feel free to
make comments too there's lots of people
here who write about the 1970s and it
would be great to hear from
people not just with questions but with
your own thoughts as well
and if you just introduce yourself yeah
hi my name's michael christopher so i'm
at delphi university here in the suburbs
of new york um
i i actually uh come to this um
gathering uh from a slightly different
perspective i'm a historian of the 1970s
in france
and uh your panel said crises of the
1970s it didn't say in the united states
it was pretty obvious that's what it was
going to be about but but i i wonder
though if uh by broadening out the
perspective and looking at this
comparatively
uh there might be something to be gained
uh particularly in in problematizing
some of the questions of you know is
this a period of crisis or one of of uh
you know a bridge between two eras
um
and because comparatively i mean if you
look at there there definitely are some
real crises uh that are seen in in many
different countries it's not all just a
discursive creation uh definitely
there is a slowdown of the world economy
there's no doubt about that and it's
happening in western europe it's
happening in eastern europe as well it
doesn't matter whether you're in the
communist world or the capitalist world
and there's i think definitely also a
crisis of governance
uh that is happening in many different
countries uh and you know you have
reflections of that like the creation of
the trilateral commission that was
supposed to deal with this this
international crisis of governance um
and that also is happening in both the
communist and non-communist world
um
and and some of these other problems
like the the issues the of the family uh
you know the the history of the family
demographic history there there are
similarities between europe the united
states the baby boom existed there as
well
um and and even when you get to the
question of uh carceral issues uh in
western europe in the 1970s you have
very important efforts to reform prisons
um and one of the the more significant
products of this that many of you would
be familiar with would be the work of
michel foucault discipline and punish in
in france you have a very important uh
prison reform movement that he's
involved in that results in a very
different outcome which is for example
the abolition of capital punishment in
france in the early 1980s
so uh
so maybe there's something to be gained
by looking at the fact that these crises
are some of them at least are
international uh and and by comparing
the outcomes in different countries
perhaps we can learn more in a sense
which is a a creation of of of the
particularities of american politics uh
or the american situation which you know
uh reflects a more underlying sort of of
of problem in uh in
world history
and if anybody wants to speak to that in
particular
um
i
really think is this time
no i don't know okay um i think that's
an excellent point and this i wanted to
just clarify though that this question
of whether a crisis is real or not again
i point us to robert's comments it's a
question of crisis for whom and why does
it become a crisis i mean you can even
have economic slowdown you can have all
kinds of changes you can have
catastrophic changes but but whether or
not they become crises
and crises for whom often have to do
with the responses to them so when you
have an economic crisis for example you
can either respond to it by greater
redistribution of wealth or you could
respond to it by clamping down on
redistribution of wealth
so i mean i thoroughly agree with the
point of international comparison but
again with this idea of crisis i think
we need to be very contextual and very
historical about for whom
and how might it not have been a crisis
because change and crisis are not
synonymous transformation and crisis are
not synonymous
i just uh is
i don't know if this is on or not
is it on no no not really
okay
um okay then i'll just yeah i also want
to uh uh thank uh gentlemen for the
comments and say that what it seems to
me that one of the things that
could certainly be on the agenda for
historians of the 1970s is to think
about
whether we internationalize that
question of economic downturn or not
is to look at the relationship between
the broad economic shifts of the decade
and some of these other questions in
very close empirical ways
um
geographers and others in the david
harvey school in the martin martial
school have done a fairly good job at a
fairly abstract conceptual level but
historians have really not weighed in i
think to that debate and i just i think
with this morning that paul brookman has
a piece in the times about
uh if you look at
global distributions of wealth and
global class structures in the last half
century that you see these two spikes
right and one is the upper class the one
percent in the west and the other is
essentially the rising chinese middle
class and what lies in the middle is
essentially the working class in the
industrial west right so i really think
that there is a way in which we can
think about the 1970s as representing a
true crisis for the industrial working
class of the west the crisis from which
it's yet to recover
um and that particular crisis ties into
all of these in all kinds of ways
because the notion that the white
working class in the united states is
is in the midst of an economic crisis is
mobilized in all of these conversations
politically mobilized to do other kinds
of work uh right rather than to address
as you as you as you point out and so i
think there are real connections and i i
agree i think thinking about this in a
global way makes a lot of a lot of sense
hey friends i'm rick pearlstein i write
about the 70s
collective enterprise i'm proud to be a
part of is attested by the high
value of this discussion
um robert i'm referring you to my notes
of what you said so let me know if i got
it wrong uh you talk about the family as
a site of
furious contestation on the center left
uh because feminist critiques are the
nuclear male breadwinner family is
oppressive created a crisis for welfare
and rights liberalism that could not be
easily resolved through existing
1930s and 1960s institutions
can you elaborate on that
um
sure it's all an american event it's all
all in the family
uh yeah right i mean i i i guess i i i'm
i'm suggesting
uh that
for the center right
family becomes less a crisis than a
political opportunity but for the center
left it's a real crisis which is to say
that
their emerge within the center-left
coalition
um really beginning in the 1970s
beginning 1960s clearly with the rise of
the black freedom struggle but then
compounded by the rise of feminisms the
rise of lgbt rights and
all kinds of social uh social justice
and rights projects on the left
around redefining citizenship
along lines of gender race and sexuality
that make
core understandings of family within
that center-left coalition that had more
or less been stable since the 1930s
although we could have an argument about
that i realize um
that brings those understandings of
family into real contestation and
dispute and that those
that contestation and that dispute was
um
in many ways irresolvable within
the ways in which that to my mind and my
argument that to ways in which that
particular political coalition had been
put together since the 1930s which is to
say
right that a particular idea of
breadwinner liberalism that was embedded
within
labor liberalism was very difficult to
dislodge uh in the 1970s or very very
difficult to reform certainly quickly i
think that's been a project at the
center left for the last 50 years
and it's taken that long to even come
close to
a resolution of that particular of that
particular problem so i i
i see family and gender and sexuality
alongside race as
the the core
problematics that um
uh that begin that with which the
center-left coalition has to wrestle in
those in those years
and
many on the left uh
wish that those conflicts and and
disruptions could be resolved quickly
and the argument in all the family is
that they simply couldn't be um the the
coalition was not set up to resolve them
quickly
neither were the legal and political
institutions in the larger nation state
set up to resolve them quickly so that's
a generational or two set of conflicts
that um
you know that that i think uh uh
um you know characterized the
center-left coalition from the 60s on
so that's all i really meant i mean
there's lots more details about that but
i don't want to you know i don't want to
hog the floor
well i would actually if no one is
coming up to the microphone i um if we
have a few minutes are we out of time we
have time okay um i would actually like
to just throw out um
a question to my fellow panelists which
is about this idea of crisis and is
about the distinction that kim was
making particularly in her talk so one
of the things that i think is
a little bit dangerous about viewing
crisis only as a kind of discursive
framework is the idea of
on the one hand what is an objective
crisis on the other hand i think kim's
quite right that people at the time kind
of understood their world through a
sense of crisis
and how you actually balance kind of
perceptions at the time the ways in
which those perceptions then ultimately
shape the policies that are happening
versus a sense of was it a real crisis
was it not i do think there's a bit of a
danger uh just kind of in going back to
the 1970s in taking some of the real
drama that people felt like was
occurring in their lives right when you
devalue the idea that people felt they
were experiencing a crisis um in some
ways there is a there is a kind of
tension with um
with the real drama that people felt
like they were understanding the real
drama of these uh of these events that
they were experiencing whether you're
talking about crime whether you're
talking about something like watergate
which interestingly i think is
increasingly disappearing from our
narratives of the 1970s which uh as this
panel sort of suggests um is moving much
more in a direction of kind of political
economy of social history uh and you
know for many people if you said what is
the crisis of the 1970s the first thing
that they would uh that they would say
was watergate so anyway i i don't have
any resolution to this tension but it's
something that i want to throw out see
if anyone else wants to comment on and i
know we have another person up at the
microphone here so
do you want to speak to that first
yeah
this is fine it doesn't seem like it's
i think it's okay as long as you can you
you can hear in the back
i really that's a really uh
important formulation and i think that's
actually one of the things that occurred
to me as i was listing all the crises is
that there is a particularity that we
also need to be careful about which
crises i mean not all not every crisis
as characterized as the same and and
some may resonate
more in real time than others and some
may be more creative than others
but but i would say that this idea of it
was felt as crisis at the time again
just as a slight
um i don't know a complication of that
again i think it depends who we're
talking to if you were a feminist in
1971 this was a moment of enormous
possibility
if you were a prisoner rights activist
in 1971 this was a moment not a crisis
but of my god potential revolution if
you were
a trade union activist who was trying to
uh generate new good will and energy in
the trade union movement and you were
part of
minors for democracy or or teamsters or
democratic union i mean this was a
really exciting time not a crisis but
actually of finally getting rid of many
of the oppressive things that had
existed before so i guess what i would
say is that you're absolutely right that
that for some it did resonate this
crisis and we need to understand what
that meant but it's also true that it's
very particular we have to be really
clear about who are our actors when
we're talking about crisis
hi
i'm uh i'm uh steve pattnott i'm at suny
farmingdale um i this has been a really
uh a fabulous a rich discussion i'm
really very glad that it was uh that it
was here um i guess i wanted to uh just
talk for a second or ask about the
workplace there's been a couple of
discussions about sort of crises you
know the crisis of labor
um
and i know you know in general
at these things questions tend to take
one of two forms right either why didn't
you talk about my work or how does this
relate to my work so i'm going to jump
into the latter
category there um
i uh i'm i'm working on a manuscript
looking at the challenges of organized
labor in the post-war period and i'm
actually getting right up to sort of
redoing my chapter on the 70s and one of
the things that's interesting and um
uh beverly if i may
alluded to this perfectly is that you
know in doing the oral histories that
i'm doing and also the archival
materials there really is there's a
genuine sense of
turmoil of crisis in the 1970s so i'm
i'm on the one hand i'm really i'm
fascinated by this sort of turn in the
in the historiography in the literature
about you know sort of reassessing that
um on the other hand though
it's it's it can be challenging to
reconcile that with actual you know the
the first hand you know the lived
experience of
particular you know people in workplaces
talking about how
um the the culture of the workplace
changed in ways that
they found disruptive and and uh
challenging
um
maybe i'll just speak to that quickly i
i think that the
i i think that the well both i think the
focus on the workplace is very important
for thinking about the period and that
for and that both
the
uh the kind of crisis of unions both
within unions themselves the democracy
movements that were happening and the
strong the
the sense i mean that obviously the
proportion you know the the
immunization rate has been declining
throughout the 1960s but this is masked
in some ways by the growth of public
sector unionism by the relatively slow
nature of that decline and the 1970s the
conflicts become much more open much
more
nakedly hostile and much you know just
much sharper and clearer and i do think
that and at the same time the question
about what's going to happen to the
industrial workplace will there be a
post-industrial workplace
you know what what is going to replace
the motor of manufacturing as it
declines disappears moves is anything
going to come into existence
that will substitute for that and i
think these questions are very open and
alive in the 1970s and i guess this
maybe speaks a little bit to
the you know this question of the
tension between crisis is a
objective or
as a both as a kind of objective
reality versus subjective experience and
also to the sense of crisis as a
discursive construct that's used to
impose certain
visions from above versus the kind of
sense of live turmoil i actually think
that there's something
um i do think people i just i think
people the sense of kind of turmoil and
things coming to the forefront that
previously hadn't been fully articulated
i think people actually found that
frightening but in other ways exciting
even when they were losing or even when
cons the consequences for their
uh groups or class or movements were not
positive that there was still something
about the time that it was emotionally
intense and engaging
and and certainly for people who were on
you know who managed me on the winning
side of some of these battles and some
of my interviews with people um who
played uh kind of
roles from above in the fiscal crisis
uh people recall this period as one with
tremendous excitement
and energy and people view it as a
formative moment in their own lives
moments when they were kind of able to
ascend to this new position of power and
you know they were going out to dinner
all the time and it was just like and it
was like a war i mean i think that
metaphors was like our war and we were
at the helm of it um and
on the flip side i think activists also
recall it as a time when these struggles
were articulated in ways that
made them you know that that were
difficult but nonetheless
uh
perhaps easier than the sort of daily
crises that are not
don't don't emerge into open conflict in
that way so maybe something similar
might be said about the workplace during
these years but
i think i think the workplace is an
extremely important area to look at for
thinking about the period overall
uh
again i i don't know if this is on or
not it's hard to tell from up here
uh that's a great question we had a
labor historian on on the panel i mean a
true labor story that could speak maybe
to this
question in a little bit more
fine-grained detail no disrespect at all
to anyone on the panel um
but one thing that i
was actually going to talk a little bit
about but
as a result of time didn't didn't get to
which is something that i think is not
historians have not taken up yet i mean
nancy mclean's book does it
um but for a very very broad spectrum
and that's the post-1964 the post-civil
rights act workplace
and the ways in which the first couple
of decades after the creation of the eoc
and this may be less about the kind of
lived experience of work in the 70s and
more about
the workplace as a kind of legal and
political
side of contestation but the number of
eeo lawsuits the battles over
affirmative action the battles over
sexual harassment the creation of sexual
harassment law which of course there's
actually a couple of good books about
the combination of all of those things
in the wake of the 64 civil rights act
has yet really to find its historian and
to think about the the american
workplace
in through through the lens of those
transformations um uh both legal and
social and i think that's something that
that's kind of a hidden part of this of
the decade
well prior to becoming a historian of
prisons i that's what i did was labor
history and wrote on the auto industry
for many years and i will say that i was
really taken by this comment about the
workplace because
in fact that's a that's a perfect
example i think of the complexity of
what we're talking about here if you
looked at any detroit auto plant in
1968 to 1975
all of these things were happening and
they were all true white workers felt
that this was a a crisis moment they had
lost
uh uh they had lost a lot of power on
the shop floor to black workers that was
their perception right um black workers
on the other hand who were in the league
of revolutionary black workers or in
drum or even in the trade union
leadership conference felt like they
were uh finally finally getting some
inroads in the labor movement and within
the auto plants meanwhile both sets of
workers were facing an economic crisis
in the sense that management was
battling them day and night for
concessions
so it's a the workplace is actually
really important this is a pitch to
everyone's return to labor history
because in fact that is ground zero and
all of those things are playing out uh
particularly uh vis-a-vis this way in
which race is uh crises are racialized
right one person's crisis
is sometimes another person's finally i
have some say so on the shop floor or
finally i have some voice right
hi my name is pete i'm a phd student at
boston college sorry a little sick um
thank you so much for the fabulous panel
and if anybody's interested talking more
about the 1970s and is still around on
monday morning we're having a panel on
american catholics in the 1970s uh which
kind of leans into my question i was
wondering
how you see the role of religion working
in the 1970s in your projects or in the
vast literature um i'm thinking two of
david hollinger's work on liberal
christianity there's definitely a sense
of crisis transformation in the main
line and in roman catholicism and
evangelicalism just wondering how we
would work that into the conversation
and thank you so much for this fabulous
panel
other than just say yes
right other than other than just you
know as a not as a historian of religion
but as someone who's thought a little
bit about it in in my own work i
um
other than to say yes let's do it um and
certain you know certainly
within
both liberal
broadly drawn within both liberal and
uh
and mainline and conservative uh
protestantism
there's a sense of uh
you know whether it's crisis or simply
kind of re a reformulation a
re-modernizing of faith right that's how
many of the liberal protestants would
have seen it right modernizing the faith
for a new kind of a new era
um that's certainly a political project
uh
within the within liberal uh
protestantism
uh i don't know nearly as much about the
the catholic story and so i i don't want
to even wade in for fear of embarrassing
myself in front of people who know the
story but much better
um
but but clearly the questions that that
i've written about gender sex and family
are
part of they're not constitutive of that
debate but they're certainly part of a
fundamental part of that debate
when i
looked at the conservative uh
evangelical protestant movement in the
70s and early 1980s and waded into
those archives i was
a little bit surprised to find that
overwhelmingly
the two major issues i mean there are
lots of things being talked about
pornography and all kinds of things
but overwhelmingly right if you just
sort of took it as a mat as a mass of
archives what what are the what are the
spikes the spikes are overwhelmingly
abortion and the perception that there's
a secular religion being taught to
children in the schools overwhelming
those are right and there really is very
much a sense of crisis around those two
those two questions in effect that a
kind of
either a modern christianity or more to
more to the point a a
secular religion
um was being imposed on on
on especially their especially on
children but there's a much much more to
say about it and i'm not the person to
say it unfortunately
uh jonathan gentry brown university um
my initial question was about
globalization which i thought was a word
that would get mentioned more in crisis
about the 70s but i think that's already
been addressed a little bit but what i
what i wanted to talk about or ask you
guys about
was one of the interesting threads
throughout here was the transformation
of the state and the relationship of the
the citizen to the state uh whether
that's uh enfranchisement transparency
war on drugs the war on crime and just
wondering if you could elaborate on or
maybe even conceptualize
what this transformation is particularly
in the context of
narratives of retreat
or else
is the state sort of going after
citizens in a new way to sort of bring
them in uh yeah so relationship of uh
the citizenship in the state
actually like i also i had wanted to
something else for myself but i think
the
i just wanted to highlight the kind of
contrast between beverly's ideas or the
the idea of the moment is that kind of
the 70s as seeing an increase in
transparency in certain ways and
engagement and the sense of the state
becoming more repressive or just how to
reconcile these two
different
trends
well i can talk a little bit to um to
the intelligence agencies and
particularly to
the fbi and i do think that you have to
some degree a kind of paradoxical story
when you look at an institution like the
fbi but you put that in conversation
with the sorts of things that heather uh
is doing and many other people donna as
well
um so for
for the fbi
the 1970s was both a period of crisis in
the sense that uh someone like j edgar
hoover dies uh and he had been there for
48 years many people declare that a
moment of national crisis but it is it
is a crisis that is also an opportunity
and so it opens up a lot of questions
about what's going to come next and i
would just highlight two things that
really come out of that so one is a much
deeper and much more widespread
knowledge of the repressiveness of that
institution up to that point of the ways
in which largely because of the church
committee but because of many other
congressional committees because of the
press um and uh other factors as well
but the amount of knowledge that
americans have by the mid to late 1970s
about what intelligence agencies like
the fbi have been up to certainly in
terms of domestic surveillance in terms
of
a whole host of other activities and the
cia as well right those are dramatically
different knowledge systems that people
are using to relate to their government
and it's pretty dramatic uh so i think
that's one piece you actually see a
genuine opening of knowledge foia
becomes much more effective
congressional committees are much more
inclined to uh to um publicize this kind
of knowledge so that's piece one is a
real opening
and piece two of what happens with the
intelligence establishment the fbi in
particular is that you begin to get
really genuine new restraints on the
kinds of activities that they can engage
in
which you could also argue is a kind of
democratize a genuine democratizing move
you have congressional oversight for the
first time um you have a series of
restrictions now many of those are
incomplete and many of those are lifted
but certainly from the perspective of
the intelligence agencies they
understand themselves to be in crisis
and uh but i think from a kind of
citizens and democratizing perspective
you actually get an opening of what's
going on at that level that arguably
doesn't last very long but uh that's the
story there at the same time that you're
actually getting a much more
repressive kind of criminal justice
system coming into play so i don't think
it's a straightforward story
um i'd like to add to that in looking at
the war on drugs i think that the
rockefeller drug laws are very important
i wanted to highlight the new work
that's being done that places it in a
much larger context in a post-war
context where you see mandatory minimums
established in california in d.c for
example in the 1950s but certainly the
development of mandatory minimums and
the focus on street-level drug dealers
and users as the real
central
um focus of policing in the state is
very important and of course after the
passage of the rockefeller drug laws 48
other states
develop and pass similar laws so i think
that it is absolutely important on the
other hand i think it's important to
place it within this larger history of
really bipartisan support for uh
increasingly punitive criminal justice
the other thing that i would highlight
is this redefinition of
drug addicts and drug users as agents of
crime
that this is a profound shift from
medicalization the use of methadone
programs and things that are viewed as a
public health crisis
prior to this and it's a shift of course
in nelson rockefeller's own drug policy
which is a very abrupt one so i do think
that this um
in the evolving creation of the state
apparatus which is going to yield
massive incarceration really it's going
to reach its height between 1985 and
2000 that this um focus on street level
drug dealing
or drug distribution is very very
important and i actually wanted to go
back to uh answer the question that
beverly posed which i think is quite
important and i struggled with this
myself on the one hand talking about the
discursive construction of crisis
in the tradition of the birmingham
school i think is very important but
what actually brought me to study this
were was the discussion of
black panther party members and other
radical activists about how street-level
drug economies profoundly damaged the
movement in the 1970s and they
themselves while
really booed
enjoying a period of unprecedented
visibility and activism especially in
the aftermath of the passing of j edgar
hoover
in the early 70s at the same time found
themselves facing in some ways new
barriers and the drug economies
themselves were seen as very destructive
and i think one of the really complex
challenges is disaggregating
state and media generated discourses of
crisis from the voices of ordinary
people living in neighborhoods who
aren't who see themselves as affected by
crime and drug economies and one of the
dangers is the appropriation of
particular voices by the state in order
to support specific agendas so that goes
back to both
robert and heather's point about crisis
for whom
so i think it's a real challenge about
how we
create a dialogue between kind of state
and media generated ideas of crisis and
what that says to oral histories and
grassroots accounts of that because
certainly that does exist and i think
this issue becomes even
an even more potent issue during the
crack crisis in the 1980s
hi i'm joanna ddas postdoc at stanford
and this might just be another way to
ask a similar question um i'm just
specifically interested in cointelpro
and
your opinion about its role in creating
or manufacturing a crisis of violence or
in being destructive to the black
freedom movement or am i
granting cointelpro too much agency in
that are they not actually as big of a
factor as i feel that they are so just
your your guys opinions about cointelpro
and its role in manufacturing a crisis
or sort of a destructive force thanks
um i'll respond to that quickly so
cointelpro just uh definitionally stands
for counterintelligence program um it
was program run by the fbi or really a
series of strategies that the fbi
adopted actually beginning in the 1950s
initially against the communist party
and then expanded throughout the 1960s
to target a lot of organizations on the
left but actually interestingly also
organizations on the right so at least
some of cointelpro was actually directed
at the ku klux klan um and other
right-wing organizations um so i think
what is and and the question is how much
of crisis in these kinds of cases is
actually being generated by the state
and being deliberately generated by
in this case the federal bureau of
investigation and i think that the
answer is
some but maybe not as much as they
wanted you to think on some level so i
think you know the fbi under cointelpro
absolutely did things like um attempt to
for instance um in black radical
organizations you know attempt to
disrupt radical organizations by
um sending anonymous letters from the
leader of one organization to the leader
of another organization saying you know
you're a jerk or your girlfriend's
sleeping with so and so and did you know
that and so and so just you wouldn't
believe what so-and-so has been saying
about you they also extensively had
informants within radical organizations
who were there to uh sometimes to foment
violence often just to kind of foment
internal dissension and i think those
had really dramatic impacts uh in
particular cases on uh radical
organizations but i actually think the
most damaging parts of an operation like
cointelpro
or of fbi surveillance much more broadly
was then the belief that developed that
fbi agents were everywhere fbi and
formers were everywhere so whether they
were or not right that became a really
important part of movement culture again
whether you are within the ku klux klan
uh or you're in uh in some sort of
left-wing organization and so that
perception and that fear even before
cointelpro was itself uh as well
documented as it is today i think is a
really critical part of uh of the
movement cultures of the 1970s and for
me one of the most interesting questions
about uh social movements and the state
during this period and i think there are
a lot of places uh to do work is the
ways in which they were kind of mutually
constituting each other and mutually
responding to each other so that is a
quick answer to the cointelpro questions
i also have an answer to that wearing my
earlier hat as a panther historian
uh no pun intended but um
cohentel pro and thinking about the
history of the black panther party um
jacob hoover defined it as the greatest
threat to the internal security of the
united states
oh can you is this working can you hear
me so um j edgar hoover defined the
black panther party as the greatest
threat to the internal security of the
united states so the party itself was
the recipient of an incredible number of
of cointelpro programs and directives
and i think that the most
glaring effect that it that cointelpro
had on the panthers was to initiate a
really fractured fratricidal um
matricidal split in the party between
the new york chapter and east and west
coast chapters new york and california
and that was done through a series of
letter writing campaigns between huey
newton and eldridge cleaver and it
extended much deeper than the leadership
so you had massive infiltration of the
panthers
one interesting fact that came up during
the discussion about richard aoki and
his status or non-status as an informant
over seth
with seth rosenfeld's book was i had a
discussion with some of the oakland
leadership about this and their own
estimates is that they
and this may speak partially also to
beverly's point it requires further
research is that their own estimates
that there were up to 700 informants
inside the black panther party
looking at some of the oral histories
that have been done of previous
organizations like the revolutionary
action movement and the communist party
i think that questions of infiltration
these organizations are very important
they're problematic in documenting and
finding definitive documentation but i
think there's a lot that we don't know
about levels of infiltration and
surveillance inside radical
organizations but in the panthers that
split between the east and west coast
branches of the party was incredibly
destructive so
it really
one of the
ways that intelligence operated was to
take things that were pre-existing
cleavages and then to actively
manipulate them so you had the division
between the oakland and the rest of the
country because of its democratic
centralist structure it was not demo it
it was not incorporating leadership from
other parts of the country and this was
actively used and then it took
individual and personal antagonisms and
manipulated that through correspondence
but i think there's still much more
research to be done on this and the kind
of um spectacular debate we had about
richard aoki and the black panther party
i think is just an indicator of of the
additional research that needs to be
done
yeah i think that's a wonderful question
in no small part because one of the
reasons we're all here to work on the
night we're interested in the 1970s and
the answer to that question
is so important to how we already
understand the 70s and what do we not
know about the 70s and donna and i have
talked about this a lot i mean in part
um if it's if it's true that the fbi was
less involved than it wanted to be or
had less of an impact than it maybe
wanted to be which
which i could make that argument that
has an impact on the history of the 70s
and how it unfolded if it's also true if
on the other hand it's true that we
don't even know the half
of what was going on remember we don't
even know about cointelpro had it not
been for the break-in right had it not
been for media and in my own research on
attica indicates that cointelpro is
probably the tip of the iceberg that in
fact there that every organization had
their own kind of version of cointelpro
that kind of deep level investigative uh
apparatus to figure out what's happening
on the ground now whether it was
effective or not i mean
partially we can't answer that because
we
accessing those documents is very
difficult but i will say that for
example at attica
this is a relative this is a a prison
rebellion in a small town in upstate new
york and within hours of it taking place
there are memos going from the prison to
the buffalo fbi the buffalo fbi to the
national fbi and then everybody is cc'd
on what's happening at attica from the
president the vice president the army
the navy the the marines i mean like
every branch of the military
and then later on fast forward when we
have the attica trials there there is an
informant in the uh the attica brothers
legal defense and does that shape the
outcome does that happen
i mean i suspect it does
but
to be able to document that and locate
that is very difficult and yet we must
do that if we're going to fully
understand that history of the 70s
hi i'm aaron scott from princeton
university i was wondering how you might
characterize the spatial elements of the
crises that you're describing i think
heather briefly met had a commentary
said a lot of your work used to soul
overfall under the rubric of the urban
crisis so i don't know are the crises in
the 1970s felt or perceived to have felt
differently in different places
different regions is there category of
urban crisis useless or do we need
useful anymore do we replace it with
something else
wow
that's a great question i mean actually
when i said that i think i was speaking
more kind of historiographically that we
thought about we were all trying to
figure out cities and what had happened
to cities and there was this framework
uh very much a credit to tom segrow's
work that we had an urban crisis and we
were trying to figure out where we got
it
and how deep it was and for whom um and
i feel like we're now
at a level of specificity maybe now more
if we're actually investigating those
crises at a different level and then
part of it is just you know how we
identify ourselves as historians in
given moments maybe
i don't know if that to me that's what
it felt like but
briefly i think your your comment uh
makes me think of the recent article in
the jh by andrew sandoval strauss about
latino urbanisms and
um
and i do think it's interesting i mean i
think this is a moment
i think the earlier question of
globalization brought this up for me as
well
you know that the
well just the the the way in which the
uh
certainly what's happening during the
70s plays out differently in different
parts of the country and also people are
naming and labeling or trying to
understand a set of changes that we can
obviously see much more clearly in
retrospect but i think the idea of
globalization and the idea of
kind of how
cities might
come back from some of the problems that
the northeast and midwestern cities
might come back from some of the
problems that were especially pressing
at that time
we can see these things now in a way
that people at the time were trying to
understand make sense of
and interpret and
that the whole framework of
globalization or of a post-industrial
economy or of
gentrification and what that would mean
and different of new immigration flows
and how those would change
cities all of those are
are
just coming into existence and people
are grappling at the time to try to
understand those so i i guess that
that's one way of thinking about it and
i i also i might be asked your other
point i think that there is definitely a
strong
regional component to this and it would
be interesting to know and i don't you
know to what extent did
southwestern cities like phoenix talk or
think about a crisis at the time so
i think we have time for
maybe one or two more questions
hi my name is uh irving kagan i'm the
chair of social studies at hunter
college high school
um i was interested in in just simply a
question of etymology and
um how often the word crisis is used
in the 60s or 50s and 60s versus 70s and
how it might be used
just sort of thinking back
crisis earlier seems to me to be applied
to foreign policy
u2 crisis cuban missile crisis and i'm
also thinking about mcnamara saying at
some point
um
you know there's no such thing as
strategy anymore there's just crisis
management so this notion that
you know emergency measures have to be
taken or
there's there's no way to plan for these
problems i guess i'm wondering uh did
this term leak from foreign policy into
domestic policy and then also
thinking about the media um
you know framing the 70s is the cube i'm
sorry the iranian hostage crisis
where
every night we counted how many days
we were in crisis and i i wonder what
role
it became just a meme that
was used for everything
thanks
yeah thank you for that question i have
just a very quick comment about it it's
interesting in an early
earlier iteration of my paper
i had um a line that said something like
um crisis could be used not only in the
international context but to mobilize
domestic wars and that i ended up
shortening it but that made me think
about that relationship between crisis
and war because in my case talking about
the overlapping domestic wars wars on
drugs wars on crime wars on gangs that
crisis and war go together in such
profound ways and
uh whether that's historical or it's
discursive i'm not sure but i think
the way that one of the ways that i see
them linked is the way that susan sontag
talked about war that war the use of war
of them as a metaphor
calls for one the mobilization of
unprecedented resources and two
a notion of something abstract that can
never be fully won or completed when
you're talking about it domestically so
a war on drugs can never ultimately end
domestic drug consumption so i think
that's it might be interesting to think
about what that relationship is between
crisis and war and given the nature of
the imperial nature of the american
state how profoundly this idea of crisis
in foreign policy helps provide the
language and
even
the conceptual idea of how to mobilize
state resources
i think we have one is there one more i
think i think that's a great question
and there's there's a lot more to say
about it i think we might have one more
questionnaire though so maybe we should
go
with that and talk afterwards
um
so um i'm suzanne i'm from columbia
university and i my question was about a
lot of people have mentioned demographic
change
um but it hasn't really i think it's
been discussed that much and i was
curious about
how
the democratic demographic changes that
are happening in the 1970s intersect
with political institutions to create
real if not crisis imperatives for
changing actual political institutions
that might be distinct from the crises
that the media is discussing
um
what specifically you mean yeah so i
come at that from the perspective of
rising divorce rates and how
divorced women then approach um
the social insurance system that's built
around breadwinners and homemakers but i
was also curious about the rising number
of
or the just
massive influx of um
young people into the
to the voting pool that beverly
mentioned earlier and how that might
have actually affected political
institutions
well on that front i will say though
people thought it would be you know a
dramatic transformation like many things
like i mean like many political reforms
right it both is a dramatic
transformation and then it turns out
that it doesn't actually transform a
whole lot although honestly i don't know
that we as historians i mean there may
be a good political science literature
on that question and there probably is
though i think we as historians really
on any number of the kinds of reforms
that i just started listing off i don't
think we've actually looked in a serious
way of what the consequences of those
reforms have been
i would just
say very briefly sudan and you you know
this as well as anyone given your
research that that part of that
center-left project that i talked about
right is is an attempt to in a way kind
of rethink the social contract
and so whether it's you know divorced
women whether it's questions of child
care whether it's questions of social
security and the the nature of you know
who's included and not under what terms
right there's a myriad set of questions
that emerge
out of whether you want to call them
demographic changes or changes in the
structure of american households maybe
it's a better maybe a more a broader
term that might be more
well actually maybe more specific term
uh
then i think that the center left
project is to really try to
reconceptualize the nature of of social
provisioning and what the social
contract looks like and that's where so
much of the conflict right emerges is
how is that done can it be done given
the way that that social contract was
imagined you know 50 years earlier
so absolutely but what comes out the
other on the other end
i think is less probably a renegotiated
social contract than something that
looks more like
rights liberalism right so you have you
have a certain kind of rights project
that wins
but a different kind of social
provisioning for the most part doesn't
end up right
winning the day
i think
that i think that last question actually
brings us the echo some of the other
questions that have been asked about
the change the kind of changing nature
of the relationship between citizens and
the state
and i think it it highlights also this
kind of tension between changes in
political institutions and changes in
political economy and society more
broadly and perhaps this the one of the
things that's you know compelling about
the decade or about the the period is
this
parallel set of changes that it's not
just that the ideology or the framework
of the social contract is compact is
shifting although it is
and it's not just that the nature of the
population and the kind of deep social
structures of household family workplace
and economy are changing although they
are but there's this kind of dual
set of changes that are happening and
the challenge is how to understand and
think about those
going forward so
i think unfortunately we are just about
out of time
but thank you to everybody both in the
panel and in the audience
for a really helpful discussion
you're watching american